yeah
[Music]
everyone thanks so much for coming out
today my name is Wes vos I come all the
way from Canada I did actually grow up
learning French so if you want to try to
talk to me in some french-canadian I
might be able to understand here today
I'm going to talk to you about a sink
await and the reason why I want to talk
to you about yes thank you somebody
laughed at that joke can we just take a
second to appreciate my hilarious joke
thank you thank you I want to talk to
you about a sink away today because flow
control in JavaScript it's really hard
so how many of you show of hands how
many of you are using promises in your
code date today right now okay cool
quite a bit I'm gonna go go quick review
through promises just because this is
the foundation of a sink away promises
in JavaScript are sort of like an IOU
for something that's going to happen at
some point in the future so this could
be an ajax call returning data this
could be accessing a user's web cam once
they hit the allow button on the little
pop-up that shows it could be resizing
an image the point is that all of these
things take time and with promises we
simply kick off the process and then we
move along with our lives we only come
back to that thing when we need to to
deal with the data so but why do we do
it this way in JavaScript and that's
because JavaScript JavaScript waits for
nobody
it's simply everything in JavaScript is
a synchronous meaning that we kick off
the process and we come back to it when
we have to deal with the data or deal
with the response so let's relate this
to real life something that maybe you
did this morning which you you want to
make coffee you want to drink your
coffee you want to cook your breakfast
and you want to eat breakfast would it
make sense to finish making coffee
before you can even start cooking your
breakfast would it make sense to make
the coffee drink the coffee and then
once you're done then you can go ahead
and and start making your breakfast no
that doesn't make sense we want to
really just kick off the process of
making coffee and then come back to it
and deal with the result accordingly so
how we sort of dealt with this in the
past
is something called Christmas tree
callback Al and we would write code that
looks like this we've all written
terrible terrible code that may probably
got a little bit more it looks like a
Christmas tree if you go on the side
what's really cool about that is the
promises allow us to start writing code
like this where we can run our functions
make coffee make breakfast and they
return a promise not the data a promise
that the data will come at some point in
time and then we can use dot then to
listen for the data actually coming back
we can take it one step further and sort
of wrap it in a mega promise by saying
promise dot all and that will allow us
to wait until both of those things are
done until we go forward and deal with
the result in this case eat our
breakfast and drink our coffee another
example let's say we were building a
little animation library where we want
to do one thing after another well
rather than doing the callback hell on
the table what we can do is kick off
move to which will return a promise and
then we can chain our dot vens whereby
returning a promise from each subsequent
one so this is really exciting because a
lot of the new browser api's are being
built on promises so we've got fetch or
you can fetch your data then that will
come back we convert it into JSON and
then finally deal with that data at the
end of the day we can use a library
called Axios which is really exciting
where it has some it's like kind of like
fetch but it has some really good
built-in defaults where we don't have to
have that second and then chained
although on the one there's many many
more browser api's payment requests
dealing with credit card data in the
browser getusermedia getting access to
the web cam web animation api all of
these things are being built on standard
promises it's really easy to make your
own with promises as well so here we
have a function called sleep where it
takes in the amount and the way I
promise works is immediately you return
a promise and then what you do inside of
that promise is you either resolve it
when things went well or you reject it
when things didn't go well so in this
case after 500 milliseconds we're going
to resolve it with some data or if it's
less than 300 milliseconds I'm going to
reject it because that's too fast and
what that will allow us to do is a
little bit something like this where we
can write our code and then we can chain
and then then on it and by returning a
new promise from each one we're allowed
to keep going and chaining that code
along the way look at it promises are
really really great but the then I'm not
happy with it right it's still kind of
callback II and any code that needs to
come after the final promise it all
still needs to go into that final dot
then it can't just be top level in your
current function this is where a sync
awake comes in is sort of saves the day
a sync oh wait is still based on
promises but it's just a really nice new
syntax for working with it so we looked
at this example earlier we went from
callback to promise based well what we
can do now if you look at the bottom
here is we can simply make a function by
tagging with a sync and then inside of
that we simply put the awake keyword in
front of each of those functions and
that will simply sort of pause the
function from running it will wait until
that promise resolves until it moves on
to the next line of code no thenns no
callbacks needed so let's break it down
javascript is almost entirely a
synchronous non-blocking we talked about
that is great that we can create these
experiences without having to lock up
the browser whenever we do anything but
it's hard to read it's sort of hard to
author this code so if we look at PHP if
we're not using any threads or anything
we wanted to go ahead and fetch two
things from github what we would do is
we would fetch the first one and when
that comes back we would fetch the
second one and then when that comes back
we have both pieces of data and we can
go ahead and use them reads really nice
top to bottom
not so great because why am I waiting
for Wes to come back before I go off and
fetch the Scott in JavaScript what we
can do is we can put both of those
promises into variables and then wait
until both of them come back they can
both fire off one after another and then
we can wait for both of them come back
and then we can use the data by creating
some HTML and displaying it on the page
so the PHP is kind of easier to read but
the JavaScript is more performant
because we're not like waiting on
unnecessary things to finish but I'm not
really happy with either so a sink away
gives us synchronous looking code
without the downside to actually writing
synchronous code so how does it work
first thing we need to do is mark our
function as a sink so you still keep
your regular promise functions nothing
changes with your functions that we
return a promise what we do now is we
create an a sync function by writing the
word a sink in front of it then when
you're inside of an a sync function you
simply just await things inside of it so
you can either just await the sleep
function and that will just wait until
it the promise resolves or if you care
about what's coming back from that
promise maybe it's some data from an API
then we can store that in a variable so
really it's it's the best of both worlds
let's take a look at another example
here so in this case I'm sticking it
into a variable and that's another way
that we can write it and here I'm doing
the PHP thing where I await Axios yet
and then when that comes back I'm going
to await the second Axio second that's
kind of slow we don't want to do that
right so what we can do is we can simply
await promise dot all and by passing
promise that all our other two promises
we sort of make one big mega promise
that we can await for both of them to
finish so one takes one second one takes
two seconds it's going to wait the full
two seconds before we go on to the next
line of code now that's great but if
you've ever seen any examples online the
error handling starts to ugly it up so
let's look at a couple options that we
can use for actually working with error
handling first option for error handling
is just don't write bad code and you
don't have to handle errors I'm joking
guys don't actually do that you always
have to handle your actual errors really
the first option is and this is probably
likely what you have seen online if
you're looking at any examples it's use
a try/catch so just wrap everything in a
try-catch and you're gonna be nice and
safe and the way that that looks is you
have your sync function you give
yourself a try write all your code
inside the try and then if anything
happens inside of that try
you catch the error in your catch and
you deal with it accordingly second or
third option is a higher-order function
where which is kind of cool because you
can chain a dot catch on a sinc
functions so this is a little bit more
complicated you might have to come back
to these slides and look at it but let's
walk through an example so I've got a
function Yolo
where I don't care about error handling
in this function I'm gonna assume
everything works great then I'm going to
await something that maybe gives me a
404 and is going to break because no
data came back this could be a syntax
error this could be any error that Axios
might throw you then this is where it
gets a little bit hairy so stay with me
will you create a high order function
called handle error that takes as an
argument the actual function and then
from that you return a new function so
you basically just return the same
function but with a catch tagged on to
the end and the catch that's tagged on
to the end that's where you actually
handle your error if you're a hotshot
and you're using es6 for absolutely
everything you can do it in one line and
then tweet about how cool you are
but I still don't understand exactly how
all of that works so the way it actually
works right we created our one function
that had no error handling and then we
created this weird high order function
that takes in the function and returns a
new one then what you do is you just
pass your unsafe function to handle
error and that will sort of create the
new function that still does the same
thing but it's now a little bit safer
and able to actually handle any errors
that might happen inside of that
function and this is I've myself I find
this extremely handy in note and Express
how many of you write Express Apps hands
up okay probably about half of you so
let's say we've got an orders page and
when you hit the orders page we want to
find the how are the orders for the user
right so if there were no orders let's
let's throw an error but this could be
any type of error syntax or whatever now
normally in Express you need to call
next and pass the error too next right
but and then what would happen is that
route would not render it would pass it
along your middleware line and then at
the bottom of your middleware Express
would render out an error page with the
subsequent error code and error message
but that's good but it doesn't really
cover errors that we throw you have to
explicitly call next for that to work
it doesn't handle unexpected errors or
syntax errors or database connection
errors or anything else that has
happened along the line of your
middleware so what we need to do here is
we need to catch all of our errors and
pass them along to the next function we
want to pass any error and pass it along
to the next function so this is where
our higher-order function comes in so
I'm going to create another one of those
weird functions that takes in the
function and returns a new one but in
this case I'm just going to return the
regular request response next function
and chain a dot catch onto the end and
the dot catch all it does is calls next
with the with the error that gets put
along to it again if you're a hotshot
there's an error there's one there you
can do in an arrow function now this is
how we implement it we've got our catch
errors function then we write all of our
routes or all of our controller
functions without any error handling in
it and then you can take your controller
get orders and pass it to catch errors
and that's really really nice because
you can write all of your routes without
having to worry about specifically
handling the error in the exact same way
and then you can just wrap each of your
routes in this catch errors function the
fourth option is handle the error when
you call it so sometimes you do want to
handle the error when you call it
because you say oh this is a special
case if there's an error here I need to
handle it in a different way so it's
pretty simple you make your a sync
function called load data and maybe an
error happens and that when you call it
you can just chain a dot catch on to the
end and then deal with the error however
it is that you'd like to do that fifth
option this is really important if
you're writing node node will soon exit
the process
if your promise is rejected meaning that
if you have any code that doesn't handle
an error on a promise the entire process
will exit and then that could mean your
app actually goes down so pretty simple
you just listen for the unhandled
rejection event and then when that
happens you can deal with it accordingly
probably send it off to some sort of
error handling service so that you can
log it and deal with it in your in your
code so I'm really really excited about
a sync oh wait
I was excited about promises but now
that a single wait has come around it's
it's been a while since something
fundamentally changed the way that I
owed my JavaScript and I code my flow
control I was using a cinco cinco de ask
the library for a long long time which
still has a lot of really good use cases
but a lot of my regular flow control has
moved over to using a sync away so
here's a couple tips for starting today
first write your api is in promises so i
know that we can't go and change all of
our existing code that is likely
callback based or maybe you used another
promise library but you can write your
new api's in promises and you can
resolve and reject from them use a sink
a wait for flow control as we've shown
you today convert older api's with
promise a PHY so there's a bunch of
different libraries out there and node
even now ships with something on the U
tillage which will allow you to take any
standard call back based function where
the error comes first in the callback
comes second you can just convert that
to return a promise
rather than having a call back and
that's really nice because if you're
dealing with any older API where you're
doing less a library that's called back
base you can still use it with a sink oh
wait finally choose an error handling
strategy take a look at the ones that
I've explained here you'll probably need
one or two of them for your actual
application and and implement them into
your actual application so I want to
encourage you give a sink a wait a shot
I'm really excited about it I think
that's really going to change that the
way that you build your application
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]